communication mal adaptés à la
population locale insuffisance de tester
pénurie d'équipements de protection
individuelle pour les professionnels de
santé
voilà ce que dénoncent plusieurs
organisations à mayotte en pleine crise
du coronavirus le département est
aujourd'hui touchée de plein fouet par
l'épidémie
près de 2400 personnes ont été infectées
et 29 sont décédés c'est pourquoi
l'union régionale des associations
agrées d'usagé du système de santé
interpellent l ars dans un courrier elle
demande une meilleure circulation de
l'information notamment autour de
l'utilisation des masques quand on donne
des masques qu'il y ait avec des
formations des informations d'ap haddad
accompagnement à la rosée âgées non
seulement et les portes par parce que en
fait ils ont pas très bien compris après
ça mais en plus ils les jettent
n'importe où le parlement parce que ya
pas non plus d'accompagnement là dessus
pour que les grecs quelqus comprendre si
le pic épidémique semble être passé
mayotte reste toujours sur ses gardes
les associations demandent aussi
plusieurs campagnes de communication
pour inciter la population à se faire
dépister
elle s'inquiète également de l'arrivée
prochaine de la saison des grands
mariages traditionnels mahorais et
demande la mise en place d'un protocole
particulier
[Musique]